اذا تستمر المعارك في السودان لليوم
السادسه على التوالي في مواقع عديده في
العاصمه الخرطوم ويسمع دوي قوي للاسلحه
الثقيله والخفيفه في محيط القصر الجمهوري
والقياده العامه للجيش وقد درست مراسل
الجزيره اشتباكات عنيفه في منطقه المربعات
واللاسلكي جنوب مدينه ام درمان سبقتها
اشتباكات في الساعات الاولى من صباح هذا
اليوم في منطقه المهندسين وحي النخيل في
اتجاه جنوب ام درمان وذكر مراسل الجزيره
ان معارك شديده تدور حاليا بين الجيش
والدعم السريع بشتى انواع الاسلحه في
مدينه الفاشر الغربيه السودان تتركز في
الجانب الشرقي من السوق الرئيسي للمدينه
ورجح ان تكون المعارك حول معسكر لقوه
الدعم السريع بالمنطقه كما ذكر مراسلنا
استنادا لمصادر طبيه امام مستشفى مدينه
الفاشر امتلا بالمصابين نتيجه الاشتباكات
التي كانت تدور بمحيطها في الايام الماضيه
ما تسبب في صعوبات في الاسود اليها لتقديم
خدمه للمرضى
هذا وقالت مصادر محليه للجزيره ان الجيش
السوداني قصف رتلا لقوات الدعم السريع
داخل ولايه الخرطوم عن طريق الموالح
الجنوبيه انظر معنا واضافت المصادر انها
ثلاثه اشخاص من اسره واحده لقوا حتفهم
نتيجه في جاري قذيفه طائشه بالملح واشارت
الى حركه نزوح من السكان مع استمرار
الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم السريع وقد
بثت هذه المصادر عبر مواقع التواصل مشاهدت
وثق الاشتباكات الدائره بين الطرفين في
منطقه المربعات في ام درمه وتظهر اللقطات
تحليق طائره حربيه على علو منخفض وسط
استمرار الاشتباكات